hey guys Nick here we tried PlayStation
VR s latest title Farpoint with the aim
controller this is the first few minutes
after crash landing on the hostile alien
planet and it was surprisingly intense
it's important to note that the gameplay
you are seeing is captured at a lower
resolution than the PS VR headset
renders but if you'd like to know more
about the VR set up with the aim
controller check out our Farpoint
unboxing and for more on psvr
be sure to hit that subscribe button
because you are new this ship is here to
analyze a very special wave of radiation
we're all here just for that now the
universe is full of solar radiation but
what makes this radiation so special is
that it has no discernible source masses
of energy pouring into the universe from
nowhere so you can see why we're all so
fascinated by limitless energy forever
yeah if we look out the window you
should be able to see the shuttle that's
coming to pick us up the Wonder named
after the poem and we return and if we
link to the pilots POV camera you'll get
a good view of the entire station as
well as the radiation anomaly behind us
and if we're lucky we should just be
able to see the Big Dipper off to the
side - here we go
wander this is pilgrim right for you the
airlock please activate your auto
docking sequence
Roger that pilgrim this is wander Auto
docking sequence engaged Thank You
wander looking good
wanderer we're having some difficulty
sinking with your docking gear your
guidance system will take care of your
side but I think we're going to need a
second over here
Roger that pilgrim waiting on you
that's good keep it coming
wait wait I think is still not working
we're going to try a manual reboot
standby
you still having command anything on
your head
this is command now we got the same
rating here now sick
we need an engineer to go out and fix
the docking mechanism no no it's not a
big deal
wanderer wherein I am you suits we can
just open the airlock manually and most
over to you
dr. Tyson I'd rather do the spendable by
the book
look we tethered to the pilgrim boost
over to the shuttle reattach their
release the first tether it's a simple
look if we wait to schedule an engineer
we'll be stranded here another week and
the wanderer will be stuck waiting right
there are you married that's not a
useful question here well there are
people I want to get home to
ah
man does this sit right with you
tethered walk is okay with us doctor now
you're talking
okay water please maintain your position
prepare for Banco boarding
I guess we're taking a walk Roger
holding position okay I'm opening the
outer hatch houses are attached
looking good so your name it's a
seriously dr. moon yeah but for all the
playground where I am right now
[Music]
okay wait wait wait
[Applause]
welcome to coffee
by the joint
we are now airlock
well
yeah
cousin
it
Oh
great puck great for impact
great for impact great for impact for
impact
cat location report now
locations undos analyzing atmospheric
composition 23 percent nitrogen 2%
oxygen 12% potamia
warning 63% all known elements
hahaha
pilgrim this is wander come back I say
again this is wonder actual pilgrim you
copy
[Music]
see you
oh my god your shoes pickled deploy your
second earring give us a bazooka
Oh John even even common origin also
computer model holographic files
initiating recovery
[ __ ] me
assault rifle the community assault
rifle is a standard issue rifle for
unity personal it's 5:05 a fire and a
little demo account over here on the
great estate page
dr. moon dr. Tyson this is wanderer you
copy
[Music]
[Music]
you
art to assist holographic fall recovery
smoking and scan all fragments press the
highlighted button to scan the area
Eva Eva
you okay I did bro you back there live
dr. moon dr. Tyson if you can hear this
stay where you are I'll find you
hello someone there
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
yes log this okay all segments
[Music]
this place is incredible
you realize that G here is not a
constant you can actually feel the
gravitational variances
they must be swaying from 8 or 9 to like
6
what's your stood on those rugs what
kind of pathogens might exist here we
can't afford breach
I bet this place isn't even on the star
charts come on keep moving
[Music]
scan all segments
[Music]
I say again pilgrim pilgrim can you read
me this is dr. Tyson and dr. moon come
back the signal needs more power
even without the dust storm I'm getting
a low level reading over in that
direction over there could be another
survivor how far hard to be sure maybe
we should stay put
hey no look at me we have enough
emergency rations to get us anywhere the
pilgrim is we are not staying here
survivors keep moving ok ok let's do it
yes make sure you log on this recording
[Music]
once a controller over the animals to
pick it up
guided rocket the uep assault rifle has
an integrated guided rocket launcher the
targeting liner to guide the Rockets to
the designated target the uep assault
rifle can hold a total of five guided
rockets the highlighted button to fire
the secondary weapon
[Music]
I shall be a recovering complete new
holographic all are available to view
playback all recovered files
[Music]
is it the Tobin no no but it's a piece
of it must have broken off in the main
station on entry I guess we found a
power source hello anyone inside come on
[Music]
I mean pretty good shelter battery packs
we strip off the casings we can use
these to boost our signal you prep them
while yours dr. Mann
hey Ben weird here these batteries
they're all at one percent power funny
one percent is enough for six months
yeah but why are they oh hello all right
tree [ __ ] to the EMR here how do we
contact anyone thank you trying
survivors keep moving pilgrim pilgrim
this is dr. Tyson and dr. moon come back
pilgrim if you can read us you don't
know our location we're down to our last
emergency rations but we found a hab
unit there are extra rations here to
keep us going we're alive
are you please come back you need to
take a break going for a hours here last
one for my suit I'm kind of strawberry
goo
all right
okay
you mean when the pilgrim broke up on
entry I left a trail of debris just like
this right we found one piece because
we're sitting in it if we can find the
next few pieces we can calculate the
speed and trajectory of the station we
can figure out where the pilgrim crashed
are you sure about this not very but
it's all we got
I'm gonna follow the trail of debris you
keep trying the radio make sure you keep
this door locked are we expecting
company
you